hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember it so you don't have to let me
tell you a story about a brilliant
writer and director ninja he recently
passed away but when he left behind will
last forever he directed such classics
like The Breakfast Club
planes trains and automobiles Ferris
Bueller's Day Off and so forth he also
was a talented writer writing
screenplays for the national lampoon's
vacation movies home alone
pretty in pink and many more yes John
Hughes certainly seemed like the voice
of the generation then all the lone two
came around he drove it and it sucked
the baby's day out came around keeper of
it and it sucked the nahji what
Dalmatians
clubber just visited Dennis the Menace
that shitty-ass Miracle on 34th Street
remade by that what happened he was like
The Voice and then he got lost to this
slapstick inspired shit or slashed shit
as I like to call it but none of them
are as bad as the crowning achievement
of horror that is simply known as home
alone free
[Music]
this is the film where even if you saw
the previews you felt dirty how could
such a great writers stoop to such an
insulting demeaning and absolutely
unentertaining love well let's see if we
can figure it out this is home alone 3
so the movie starts with the typical
home alone music followed by the typical
home alone credits taking place in the
typical home alone setting Hong Kong
literally the first minute completely
misses the idea of the franchise 10
million dollars for the missile chiller
sounds like your clients want to build a
missile that can't be detected by a
radar
whoever possesses this chip could
dominate the entire region
what is this die hard 5 what does this
have to do at home alone that's what you
asked for
Air Force MSB 100 C series where's my
money
[Music]
seriously how do we go from a kid being
left at a house to weapons espionage
that's a pretty big fuckin leap here I
did to the toy car would slip it right
past airport security oh you know it's
because of bungholes like you that we
have to take our shoes off at the
checkpoint
[Music]
but unfortunately the bag gets switched
with some lady and the spice panic in
order to fight
[Music]
she's leaving so they need the number of
the cat through their glove cam as they
ping down the area where the woman was
dropped off and seeing how it's a John
Hughes movie my guess is it's a Chicago
suburb where everybody is rich quirky
and white Oh done missus says you were
supposed to deal with the snow promptly
weren't you guess tricked butts of
ashtrays I don't care for excuses we had
an understanding and you broke it
your word is worthless sorry I'm gonna
try to assessment so you can tell the
neighbor that I stiffed you on a snow
removal job eh this one is as
compassionate as a punch to my balls
consider this your paint I have
introduced for the silly thing
thank you this little boys Alex not
Kevin Alex he doesn't even know Kevin
that's because Kevin's not in this movie
none of the original characters are in
this movie this is because nothing about
this movie has anything to do with home
alone despite the fact that carries the
name home alone so why does it carry the
name home alone so true so Alex has the
chickenpox which means he has to stay
home from school
Hey look Scarlett Johansson's his sister
I already made a lost in translation
choking north so let's move up as Alex
stays at home he's first looking through
a telescope and misses Hess's house with
his pet rat Doris look Doris
[Music]
you know I'm actually trying to envision
the great John Hughes writing scenes
like that and then the mouths look
through the telescope and sees a cat
it's just a cat on the TV screen but
nevertheless he gets scared
Oh John Hughes you've done it again oh
oh where's my whiskey
so the spice went to a house on the
street as they know the old woman lives
on the road but they don't know which
house anyone you know it both parents
have to leave the house as the father
always goes on business trips and the
mother has to make a last-minute
presentation at her job I'll be gone an
hour at the very most I called mrs. Hess
and told her give you in law she said if
anything comes up she'll be right over
oh wait a minute what doesn't she just
said mrs. Hess watch him your kid is
sick and all alone who cares if she's a
bitch she's still babysitting whore all
right well despite that obviously pin
stupidity Alex continues to look through
his telescope
[Music]
so when looking through his telescope he
comes across the spy sneaking into one
of the houses like a reasonably smart
kid he calls 9-1-1 but the spies escape
before the cops can see
freeze no no that's too dark that's too
dark that's the old John Hughes this is
the new quirky light-hearted John used
say let's see oh I know the dog actually
freezes in place lightful Oh where's my
absent so both the mother and the cops
think Alex made up what he saw and don't
look into it anything but wouldn't you
know what the spies break into another
house the next day well that's ok though
because we know that the parents stayed
home this - oh you got be kidding me
they left again these do they leave
their fucking medicine the toy chest as
well so once again he calls the cops
the spy speed away and nobody believes
it I saw a burglar yesterday and I saw a
burglar today there was no one in that
house but there was some thing unbeli so
he figures it's time to take matters
into his own hands
first the Stephan's mrs. house I agree
Doris the next stop is the Alcott's
house what kind of burglar goes into a
house it doesn't take anything do what I
think I think I'm looking for something
special you're looking in everybody's
house cuz they don't know who has it
yes the computers will be more than
Elementary in this matter
[Music]
so alex gets a video camera and some
duct tape as the parents leave them for
a third time all right
this is comical now I mean really
comical remember what a big deal there
was in the first film when they left him
behind
and now it's just like have fun while
I'm gone son be sure to stay away from
the rat poison I keep under your pillow
so with a camera duct tape and a few
wires Ellis manages to get he's on
wireless security network the
five-year-old now has a portable
wireless security network the realism in
this movie just fuckin astounds me
so he sneaks his camera into the next
house that the spies are looking for
yeah thank God none of the houses have
babies toddlers or stay-at-home parents
sort of lucked out on that front but one
of the spies finds the car is Alex tries
to think of a plan to distract that plan
seems to backfire as the spies get the
car and examined the video recorder on
top video cameras someone's on to us
wait no no just hear me out what if it's
a five year old boy who wired a security
system in his own home come on that's
something John Hughes will come up with
it feels on quaaludes did I really just
write that where's the quaaludes so even
though they get the tape Alex drives the
car away with the chip inside they
partake in the loaded shades we have
ourselves a little slapstick as Alex
discovers the chip inside the car again
to his credit he reports it to a member
of the military and even though they
don't believe him he gives them the
number on the chip but the bad guys find
out where Alex lives as now prepare
yourself fella parents leave again I
don't even care anymore if you want your
kid to be milk carton of the week
your problem he'll this time however
they do ask missus has to watch him but
only after they left which is still
pretty damn stupid especially
considering how the bad guys binder a
taper to a chair parents of the year or
morons morons
so of course is the to our friggin boy
genius to save the day
prissy tries to trick the woman by
controlling the dog with the dog whistle
he doesn't have a dog but he has a dog
with Jerry just buys camping for fun too
I repeat there is no movement inside
permission to enter
the other spies tried to get some of the
back but of course he has transfer them
to actually that's the second John
Hughes farting joke I've seen in a week
the other one being in flubber why is he
all about the strange things coming out
of people's butts yeah I just think
we're having an off day
oh no it's not like I can just walk away
from the water that will coincide with
my phobia I'm not walking away from the
water
oh damn my extremely odd and
unbelievably rare neuroses so yeah we
get the trash just like in the other two
movies but these traps are like really
friggin precise like he has to know
exactly what spot they're gonna be on
and not be a centimeter Oh gotcha
to set these up ouch watch this scene
it's not even funny it's like something
out of a horror
Jesus and of course we have pratfall
after Polly they're not the mother
actually calls in the middle of all this
and Alec says that everything is fine no
no everything's fine
oh yeah just fighting for terrorists and
fleeing for my life but don't worry you
have deadlines to meet but it turns out
the number on the chip got to higher
authorities as they pull Alex's mother
and his siblings aside for questioning
it's Alex my other son
why what happened he may be in danger
maybe I should have left him alone 18
times he's not here he's at home let's
move
why is he in danger we think he
intercepted a top-secret electronic
device stolen from a Defense Department
contractor by a group of international
criminals working for a North Korean
terrorist organization meanwhile man
continues at home
say you ever noticed that these secret
agents suck how do you get outside the
same way you're gonna get outside it was
Annie and each turn the Christopher
Walken there oh I don't know so without
giving too much away all the fuck cares
they scream and get hurt surprise so we
please mrs. Henson the cops finally
arrived and take the spies away
Oh for what every possible thing a
parent can do wrong seven years have
been after this guy he always manages to
slip away and now a five year old
catches them this is the worst day of my
life Thanks wait a minute there's still
one more spy on the loose but it's okay
I'm parent operating a toy car lighting
imagine setting off a series of
explosions has a totally under control
Doolittle couldn't get an animal to do
all that so after all is said and done
what does the film finally end on the
father giving his son of race car as a
gift oh the irony of the iron
I finally did it I wrote some words home
alone strength ever I know I'm
contractually obligated to write at
least one more movie but this script is
so bad no studio would ever buy it what
we gonna do who hires the director of
Beverly Hills - wha-what - directed use
your genius we'll take it
[Music]
you
Oh
[Music]